fossil fuels provide 80 of the world's
energy they're growing fast so there's
clearly something special about them by
the way we're in an energy crisis for
lack of fossil fuels and they're saying
that we can rapidly replace fossil fuels
mostly with solar and wind that are
currently three percent of the world's
energy this is a total crackpot idea
that this is all gonna happen in 27 and
a half years what i consider this whole
esg argument of replaceability it's not
a real argument by people who understand
or care about energy it's a fake
argument designed to reassure us that
it's okay to get rid of fossil fuels and
we won't suffer any consequences all
right everyone bang bang got alex here
with me uh alex i thought the great
place for us to start this conversation
was uh there's an esg argument that has
been circulating it's become very
popular
and one of the key tenets of being able
to have a debate or conversation around
a topic is that if you take one side of
that debate you should be able to argue
the other side better than them
and so maybe you could explain to us
like what is the esg argument and how
does that pertain to uh energy
production and consumption
so i think
the esg movement is really employing a
broader argument that is held by many of
the world's thought leaders and i call
this the moral case for eliminating
fossil fuels
and the basic idea is that the fossil
fuels that we're using a lot for energy
today
are creating a climate catastrophe
but they are rapidly replaceable by
renewable solar and wind and therefore
we should rapidly eliminate fossil fuels
so it's got the element of their causing
climate catastrophe they're rapidly
replaceable and therefore they should be
eliminated as quickly as possible and
then what you see with esg
is esg is basically saying hey we all
know this is true right we know we need
to rapidly eliminate fossil fuels for
some reason the voters aren't doing it
uh too quickly so let's larry fink and
other people let's impose this because
we know this is the right thing so i'll
write a ceo letter and i'll tell
everyone hey you've got to get to what's
called net zero as quickly as possible
net zero means net zero co2 emissions
which is the main emission of fossil
fuels that impact climate
when you think about their argument what
would you say is the most accurate part
of their argument or what would you say
is the thing that you're like yep that
makes sense or that's a fair uh thing to
argue
the only thing that makes sense about
the argument is that if the premises
were true the conclusion would be true
so if it were true no but that's
important but
i should say i'm giving a much better
version of the argument than i think is
is usually made um but if it were true
they were causing a climate catastrophe
let's say climate apocalypse
and the source of that all of its
benefits were rapidly replaceable
then you should rapidly eliminate it now
you might think well why isn't the
market doing that if the you know
there's a lot of questions that arise
and it's ultimately because i think both
premises are false
uh but yeah i think it has a kind of
uh it makes a certain kind of sense if
its premises are true but i don't think
they're true
so let's start with maybe the first
premise of uh the climate apocalypse or
the climate change uh is being driven by
fossil fuels and uh and kind of the
whole anti-esg
um argument
what is not true about that or how do
you evaluate the
accuracy of that premise
well
so with climate you know
there's a good question of how do you
measure this so you're saying the basic
narrative is
we are in the midst of a climate
catastrophe slash climate crisis is this
why you have organizations like the
scientific american
outlets like the guardian they're using
the terms climate crisis climate
emergency has mandatory terms right so
this means we're in the middle of a
catastrophe and then the idea is it is
going to become an apocalypse if we
continue using fossil fuels emitting co2
and then that leads to rising co2 in the
atmosphere so that's that's the view and
there's a question of well how do you
measure this
and i think the most obvious way to
measure this is what's happening to the
death rate from these climate related
disasters that are getting worse i
should say if your primary focus is on
human life and this is going to be a
sticking point we'll see for esg but it
is that this is my view if your primary
focus is on human life
then climate related disaster deaths are
really interesting to study and before i
studied this issue i was suspicious of
some of the catastrophe claims but for
sure i thought obviously these deaths
are going up right i mean how could they
not be going up given how much we hear
about this deadly climate crisis and yet
what's fascinating
i learned this first in 2007 and it's
even more true today is that this is
very well documented that the climate
disaster death rate get this has gone
down
down by 98
in the last 100 years so this means that
we are 150th as likely to die from a
climate related disaster and what's
further fascinating about this is it's
never reported in the media okay you
might say the media are biased but then
even if you look at say the u.n what's
called the intergovernmental panel on
climate change their summary reports
don't mention this and isn't that crazy
reports on climate not mentioning the
death rate from climate isn't that a
kind of important thing if you care
about human life but even beyond that i
show in the book even their
multi-thousand-page
synthesis reports that are supposed to
synthesize all the best research in the
world don't mention the climate-related
uh death rate
so
what is there's this question of like
what the hell is going on there's
there's some sort of bias here
and it becomes particularly relevant to
fossil fuels because if you ask well
what drove this death rate down it's
pretty clear that fossil fuels have a
lot to do with it things like warming us
up when it's cold cooling us when it's
hot building sturdy infrastructure um
the most important one is actually
irrigation and other forms of drought
relief like irrigation is powered by
energy drought relief convoys you know
alleviating some famine in some foreign
country that saves millions of lives so
we have this fascinating phenomenon
where fossil fuels have actually made
our climate safer and nobody is talking
about this and if you if people are not
talking about the fact that we're making
our climate safer which i call fossil
fueled climate mastery how can you trust
anyone about the future if they're
denying or distorting the present
when you think about something like the
climate related deaths going down so
drastically that that's a uh
eye-catching statistic and goes very
counter to the public narrative how much
of that is a misunderstanding um a
mathematical kind of manipulation and it
used to be manipulated very high and now
it looks more like reality versus
there's technology there is better you
know weather spotting there there's all
these other things that go into helping
humans avoid these climate disasters
like what do you attribute uh the driver
of such a drastic decrease in climate
related death
oh i think it's it's all about our
mastery of climate and so part of the
crucial context that's missing from this
is climate is naturally extremely
dynamic and extremely dangerous and i'll
emphasize the dangerous part so if you
just look at so you can wonder oh well
were we somehow getting numbers wrong in
the past but actually you'd expect the
opposite to be true i think because
you'd expect um under reporting of
certain things but there are many you
know there are many news stories you
have say in the 30s when we're not
exactly that primitive and you have
millions of people dying from these
climate-related famines i mean china in
particular i have a lot of quotes about
in fossil fuels it is really just tragic
to see these talks about oh this flood
happened or this drought happened it
just wipes out millions of people and
their lives are just over forever
because they cannot cope with the
naturally dangerous climate whereas if
you think about the amount of
development that has happened our
mastery things like flood control in
that case as i mentioned before drought
relief that's really what's taken the
naturally dangerous climate and made it
unnaturally safe but part of the reason
we can't see this is we we're taught
this false view that nature including
climate is what i call a delicate
nurturer that's kind of this this uh
stable sufficient safe place and that
our impact ruins it and this is really a
myth but it's it's really widely
believed including i think implicitly by
many scientists and so we just think of
climate as perfect and then we ruined it
so it's not even on our radar that we
have actually made climate much better
by mastering it
i mean it's a fascinating thought
process of uh
literally the
anti-aesthetical view of our
relationship with climate uh do you have
like a really good example that people
could wrap their heads around in terms
of a place where humans uh have actually
made it drastically better
from a climate perspective uh compared
to maybe the the overarching uh thought
process around making it worse
i mean i can't think of any place where
we haven't made it much better because
we've made it much better in what i call
the empowered world the places with
low-cost reliable energy that you can
that you can use to develop but also the
unempowered world and so i mean you
could take either one but just just
consider the united states i mean we
have every form of climate imaginable
here which is part of why i don't worry
about the the kinds of changes people
are even speculating let alone what i
think is realistic in the global climate
system so you have something like polar
alaska and then you have swampy florida
and where i live in california is not
perfect climate politically but i think
it's a perfect climate
in terms of just you know that in that
really nice kind of dry climate near the
ocean
uh so we have every climate imaginable
and we all live really long lives and we
don't have that much trouble with
climate climate is a rhetorical thing in
our lives like it's a rhetorical
negative but life used to be an
emergency in general because people were
poor and in particular it was a climate
emergency uh because of you know even
something like a harvest so maybe a
harvest is a great example just we don't
think now of something like the dust
bowl being possible and it really isn't
possible to us now because of modern
irrigation and other modern technology
but all of this depends on machines and
the ability to use machines at a very
large scale depends on low-cost reliable
energy and that's part of why i think
fossil fuels are so crucial because i'm
going to argue this goes to the second
point but they're a uniquely
cost-effective form of energy they're
not at all rapidly replaceable by solar
and wind so i was going to ask uh the
second premise is that they are
replaceable uh and not just replaceable
but rapidly replaceable uh and i think
built into this premise is not only
rapidly replaceable but also remaining
as low cost or lower cost as uh what is
available via fossil fuels so unpack for
me this premise and what you agree or
disagree with
well to unpack this premise i actually
have to introduce a missing premise and
this is actually one of the problems
with with the argument you can think of
it as one or two missing premises i'll
break it down into two quickly
um one is the fact that the world has
woeful it like has woefully little
energy there is far more energy needed
in the world so one statistic that i
think drives this home is that there are
three billion people so three billion
individuals who in their lives are using
less electricity than one of our
refrigerators
so you just think about that like
somebody all the electricity in their
life right so washers dryers i mean
these aren't happening but you think
about incubators uh refrigeration for
vaccines lights all of these things have
to somehow take up the same amount of
electricity as a refrigerator what do
you think happens just people have
incredibly impoverished lives but there
are three billion people right now
around the world this is their life you
would consider this i'm not saying you
but just the audience
we would consider this
a catastrophe right if we woke up one
day and we used less electricity than a
refrigerator and that was our life we
would consider that a crisis and so this
is the way i think of the world i think
the world is in a perpetual state of
crisis
because for most people because of
poverty which is very very related to
what's called energy poverty uh lack of
energy and the reason i'm bringing this
in
is that the esg movement doesn't really
think about this so what they do is they
say yeah oh yeah we can rapidly replace
fossil fuels sure but they don't
acknowledge the fact that the world
needs something like four times more
energy if everyone is to be even
remotely close
to us and why should we think that what
we should have the opportunity to
flourish and others shouldn't that makes
no sense at all so everyone in the world
should rightly want to use a lot of
energy and the fact that that is not
coming up front and center and all we're
talking about is how do we get rid of
the fossil fuel we use now
but which is 80 of the world's energy
and actually growing
and we're not talking about like how to
provide energy on a much larger scale
that points to there's not much valuing
of energy and this this is the second
premise which is just energy is
incredibly valuable because energy gives
us the the ability to use machines to
become far more productive and
prosperous and so so the real thing with
the esg
is not just those two premises that are
wrong but it's leaving out the massive
need for more energy and the massive
value of energy and then that leads to
is its is its claim of rapid
replaceability uh valid but once you
look at it from the perspective i just
gave it's pretty obvious it's not right
fossil fuels provide 80 of the world's
energy
they're growing fast particularly
growing fast in the parts of the world
that care the most about cost effective
energy namely china so there's clearly
something special about them that isn't
disappearing anytime soon by the way
we're in an energy crisis for lack of
fossil fuels which have been heavily
restricted by the esg movement so that's
another blow against it um
and they're saying that we can rapidly
replace fossil fuels mostly with solar
and wind that are currently three
percent of the world's energy and that
exists as parasites on the reliable
electricity provided mostly by fossil
fuels but also by nuclear and hydro and
that do not exist at all in standalone
form for electricity let alone the 80
percent of the world's energy that is
not electricity so i submit this is a
total crackpot idea that this is all
going to happen in 27 and a half years
and in particular this idea has been
around for over a decade and fossil fuel
use has grown dramatically so what i
consider this whole esg argument of
replaceability it's not a real argument
by people who understand or care about
energy it's a fake argument designed to
reassure us that it's okay to get rid of
fossil fuels and we won't suffer any
consequences
well it feels like
to your point uh kind of market
participants people who are used to
dealing with energy who understand uh
the value of energy who understand
why you want energy versus energy
poverty
those people this isn't even a debate it
is more of a moral argument or a virtue
signaling argument that goes on at the
davos's of the world etc where people uh
say these things and it makes them feel
good it sounds amazing
right of we're gonna replace all the
fossil fuels with you know wind and
solar uh but it's just there's no path
to it and you've written a book uh
called fossil future
why global human flourishing requires
more oil coal and natural gas not less
and so when we think about this
i thought that maybe we could go through
some of the energy sources and you could
kind of talk about what we're seeing um
and let's go right to what the esg kind
of proponents i think uh believe is the
replacement which is solar and wind and
they position this as a low-cost uh
reliable renewable uh
energy source
why are they wrong today's episode is
brought to you by alto ira have you
wanted to buy bitcoin or over 200 other
cryptocurrencies in your retirement
account well now you can with alto ira
they allow you to buy bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies in a tax advantaged way
there's no account or set up fees and
it's super simple to get started you can
go today to altoira dot com pomp to get
started alto ira.com pomp invest in
bitcoin or cryptocurrencies in your
retirement account and get all the tax
advantages while still holding digital
currencies alto ira.com
whatever possible i always like to look
at this came up with climate what is
people's account of the present so if
you view the climate as in a state of
crisis if you think we're experiencing
climate crisis
then you're either ignorant or you're
not looking at the world from a
pro-human perspective which i which we
could talk about but basically i think
that with climate people are looking at
it as the goal is not advancing human
flourishing through a more livable
climate because by that standard climate
is far more livable we're far safer but
their goal is to eliminate human impact
on earth including eliminating our
impact on climate and it's really this
kind of primitive religious asceticism
and fear that just says we should let's
eliminate what we're doing well let's
just stop let's go net zero it's not
make the climate livable it's just stop
our evil impact so i think it's very
very much a primitive anti-human
religion that believes that our impact
is evil and that nature is like a
vengeful god that's going to punish us
with this kind of hellish warming and
climate change uh so i i just think it's
it's um
it's based on a total distortion
and so the point here is if somebody
doesn't acknowledge the present or they
deny or distort it i don't trust them to
predict the future and the same thing is
true i make a big point of this in
fossil future about the renewables thing
look if people said what i just said so
if they said hey look i have to admit
so far solar and wind are a disaster
because what they have done is they have
not replaced reliable electricity uh
because we don't have anywhere
resembling the batteries for that as i
calculated in the book elon musk's
batteries it cost us about 400 trillion
dollars to back up the world for three
days so that is a fantasy
or worse so basically they're a failure
because they've added a lot of cost to
the grid because we have to pay for the
solar panels and the infrastructure but
we haven't really been able to replace
any of the reliable fossil fuels nuclear
hydro because the unreliable solar wind
can go near zero at any given time and
then when we do try to get rid of the
fossil fuels or nuclear hydro such as
has happened in texas in california we
have blackouts and so we're having
problems with cost and problems with
reliability in any case these things are
nowhere near replacing fossil fuels even
in electricity let alone things like
heavy-duty transportation such as flying
or cargo ships and so right now they're
a failure but
i have an amazing explanation of how
they're going to be a wild success like
if they said that i would listen to that
explanation but instead what we get is
denial and distortion about how they're
working and a total evasion of the fact
that they're making the world worse now
i should say this is getting a lot
better intellectually because we have an
energy crisis and it's pretty clear that
we've artificially restricted the supply
of fossil fuels through esg and
political opposition to investment
production and transportation
and
unreliable solar and wind as i think we
should have expected cannot at all
replace fossil fuels which is why i was
talking to michael shellenberger who's
running for governor in california a
good friend of mine like he was pointing
out yesterday
why is nobody running for more solar
panels right now like why is it biden
not begging china for more solar panels
he's begging venezuela for more oil and
it's because
the solar and wind
this unreliable energy cannot replace
fossil fuels and nobody expects it to be
able to do so in the near future and
that's just the reality and all of these
arguments are just total crackpot
fantasy so we could get into the
crackpot fantasies but the fact that
they deny totally deny the terrible
present of solar wind is very revealing
talk to me about the crackpock fantasies
that sounds like exactly what i want to
talk about
okay well this has become one of my
favorite topics because i actually have
a this is the only thing in fossil fuel
that i can explain better now than i
could when it was when it was written
yeah i've thought a lot about this
because i don't know if you do you
happen to see those joe rogan episodes
with steve coonan or andrew destler i
have not no
okay those those are interesting just
many many people watching this i'm
guessing saw some of them so steve kunin
is a guy who's kind of known as allied
with me he's one of these people who
says yes we impact climate but the
benefits the negatives of that are far
outweighed by the benefits of fossil
fuels so i don't mean to attribute
everything he believes to me and vice
versa we have differences but we're
generally aligned in that way and then
the person who came on to kind of uh you
know be equal time was a guy named
andrew destler who's a climate scientist
from texas a m and interestingly andrew
basically made no arguments about
climate catastrophe but his his almost
sole focus were very few let's say his
almost sole focus was oh renewables can
rapidly replace fossil fuels and he and
i
uh he fortunately had agreed to debate
me uh before he did that rogan show and
so we debated in colorado and people can
look it up if they search our names and
i was just kind of astonished like how
in denial he was of the actual reality
of solar wind
and but i noticed he's relying on this
one argument that came up on that show
which is basically hey there are
academic studies that show that we can
wrap it we can do this so leave aside
like destler because he wasn't
representing the studies effectively
that's accurate this kind of thing but
here's what's going on all of these
studies are claiming
that in one way or another again we can
rapidly replace fossil fuels with solar
wind they all have three things in
common one is that they and and all of
these
all of these we know are things that
lead to indeterminate and high prices so
one is they involve things that have
never been done before
uh on a large scale and they've never
been done before and they involved doing
them on a large scale so for example one
of the mainstream ones by a guy named
jacobson out of stanford involves
hydrogen planes okay they're not we
don't have commercial hydrogen planes
this is just a total fantasy of this
even existing how it would work what the
costs would be so if you claim to know
that that will work and what the cost
will be you're a charlatan and there are
all sorts of things like this in these
schemes that are just things that aren't
working on any scale and they're
claiming they'll work on every scale so
that's number one you know it's it's
just crackpot number two
is that they involve a crash program of
unprecedented mining and infrastructure
building so you take like what's
happening with lithium prices right now
they're skyrocketing this was obvious
that this would happen because we had
this crash program of even on a small
scale but we're talking about i think
elon was talking recently about a
thousand times more lithium at least
attacking hundreds of times more lithium
how how is that going to be cheap to do
that in the next 27 and a half years uh
how is it going to be cheap to build
unprecedented infrastructure in 27 and a
half years whenever you do a large-scale
thing on a crash program your costs go
up and then the third thing that makes
it just totally disingenuous is that all
of this is supposed to happen all of
this unprecedented never done
unprecedented development is supposed to
happen in today's environment which is
very hostile to development so this is
all in an anti-development environment
which the green movement has created the
people claiming these schemes have
created this anti-development
environment where none of this can
happen you know if you're lucky it takes
10 years to approve a lithium mine in
the us and it may not get approved uh
solar and wind are radically slowed
already by green activists who are
against mining who are against
transmission lines who are against
construction so this is another example
the these three crackpot elements are
just another
nail in the coffin of this being a
movement that cares about energy they
don't care about energy they care about
getting rid of fossil fuels they're also
hostile to nuclear and hydro which is
also revealing so their whole focus is
just how do we how do we get human
beings to stop impacting the planet and
let's make up uh let's make up a fantasy
so that we're not worried so that people
don't worry about giving up fossil fuels
but we have an energy crisis that shows
we should have been worried and i just
by the way i posted the other day some
testimony i had in 2016 in front of the
senate and i told boxer and others hey
like this is gonna cause a crisis
it's obvious and they're like and they
ridiculed me because like oh you're a
philosopher you don't know anything i'm
like no i'm a philosopher so i know you
need to look at the big picture and
you're not looking at the benefits of
fossil fuels and that's why it's going
to be a disaster
so in the book along these lines uh you
have um
a section that has a number of quotes
from various people and of course as
books go uh the bigger the name the
more experience they have in a field uh
the more that i think people kind of pay
attention to what's inside the book um
and one of the folks uh that you have a
quote from is scott pruitt who's the
former head of the u.s environmental
protection agency this is an
environmental agency and uh again the
book's name is fossil future why global
human flourishing requires more oil coal
and natural gas not less and so
immediately already the esg people's
heads are in a blender because they
don't understand what is the former epa
head doing you know uh providing quote
for his book but what he says is
uh quote stepping in once again to the
oftentimes divisive but very
consequential energy and climate
conversation is alex epstein's fossil
future arguing that fossil fuels uh
fossil fuels not only have a place in
our global tomorrows but are a necessity
to human flourishing we need more not
less voices in the climate marketplace
capable of thoughtful engagement and
critical analysis alex profers both in
fossil future and it is my hope that the
amalgamation of his research data
analysis and rhetoric will yield a more
constructive conversation about our
energy and climate choices now end quote
when i read that
it tells me that the former epa
head says hey
maybe there's way more weight in the
fossil fuels uh and the importance of it
for human flourishing which he
explicitly states there uh but he's not
approaching it in a binary sense all
fossil fuels all renewable he's saying
that there's probably uh room for both
is that
a fair position for somebody like that
to take or do you think that's kind of
where the world will end up where it's
like 98 fossil fue uh fuels and two
percent renewable type stuff or do you
think it ends up being more binary where
it's either everyone moves to renewables
and like the esg argument wins and or
everything stays fossil
fuels
i wouldn't think of it as binary now one
thing to say about pruitt because some
people are going to be thinking this is
so he was very controversial head
of the epa i mean first of all under
donald trump
so that's gonna have controversy to it
no matter what uh and i've gotten a lot
of flack for uh praising him before i
knew him and certainly before he wrote
this but i i think he was very good
compared to the others
because i do think he really looked at
energy and and
negative environmental impacts in a very
holistic way and he really understands
energy much better than almost anyone i
can think of from the epa that i've ever
seen and i think it leads him to to have
make much better decisions also he was
you know he was very focused on i think
this is right he was focused on real
pollution issues so like toxic waste
sites and you know having good air
quality and good water quality he's very
focused on that versus other people who
tend to ignore that and are just focused
on co2 emissions which i don't think
should be the primary focus
at all in terms of the balance of this
kind of thing the way i think of it is
we shouldn't really care about what form
of energy we use what we want is the
most cost effective source of energy
at a given time in a given place and so
in fossil future in chapter one i lay
out what i think are the four aspects of
being cost effective so there's just how
affordability so how much does it cost
there's reliability to what extent can
you get it on demand
uh when you need it and crucially in the
quantity that you need it versatility so
how many different types of machines can
it power can it just power like
electricity that's fixed or can it power
planes and cargo ships and that kind of
thing and then scalability to what
extent can it produce energy
for billions of people in thousands of
places and the fact is right now fossil
fuels so that's oil coal natural gas
that's in order of use oil is the
biggest gas is the smallest right now
although that might
might it'll probably expand in the
future like those combined that is the
only source of energy that provides that
hits all four aspects of cost
effectiveness but
we should want other things but we want
other things to be as good or better
than fossil fuels in a given situation
so let's say for example in washington
state you have hydroelectric power and
that is probably better than fossil
fuels in washington state because it has
great resources for that and that's
quote renewable
but the it doesn't really matter if it's
renewable nothing is really renewable
because all the materials are
non-renewable but the issue is is it the
most cost effective solution nuclear i'm
a huge proponent of it's unfortunately
been made unbelievably expensive by very
irrational government regulations that i
think should be changed but i think that
would be great i think ultimately if we
play our cars right we'll have a nuclear
future that's like
so i'm all about i just want the most
cost effective energy for the most
people and right now i think you have to
recognize that means a lot of fossil
fuels but i avidly want other things to
happen
that are good so the people have this
idea like you should be partisan you
shouldn't be partisan but you need to be
objective and you can't claim that solar
and wind are really good right now when
they're not i think that in the future
they might have some potential
particularly solar but they need to be
they have to compete on a level playing
field whereas right now they get
unbelievable government preferences
including they get to sell unreliable
electricity for the same price as others
get to sell reliable electricity and
then in fact they get a subsidies they
get paid more so that's a total racket
that needs to be changed but i'm totally
open to them participating in the future
if they actually do so reliably
talk to me about nuclear in the sense of
uh obviously there's a ton of regulation
uh we've seen people shutting down
nuclear power plants we've seen uh the
prevention of building of new nuclear uh
power plants there's just an immense red
tape uh it seems like people who are
interested in this technology uh and
doing this they run into what i'll call
kind of the public narrative or the uh
the the fear that is uneducated about
nuclear uh but also there's very real
obstacles uh to making this a reliable
um kind of popular energy source both
the united states and globally what's
your read on this and kind of what is
the path forward to make nuclear energy
uh a core component of the energy mix
that humans use
i think we need to say at the beginning
there's a lot of evidence that nuclear
has amazing potential so one piece of
evidence that i i take i put a lot of
stock in for anything economic is
there's market evidence when people like
make things up about the future that
haven't been tested on the market i'm
very suspicious of them and my first
thing is why don't you do this and then
i'll believe it versus you tell me
you're gonna force it on me and then
you're promising it'll work so with
nuclear we had it quite cheap and very
reliable in the 70s before the onset of
a massive amount of government control
and regulation that i consider to be uh
criminalizing it so but we have a track
record it's very important where this is
producing low-cost reliable very clean
very safe energy and what happened is
even though nuclear is this might
surprise people but it's factually and
if you understand the physics uh kind of
obviously the safest form of energy
basically it can't explode so it can
melt down but that's a very slow process
that the damage can be contained versus
exploding which you're going to kill
people so nuclear is the safest for a
whole bunch of reasons and its track
record uh is the safest we could go into
some of the alleged disasters that
disprove this but i think it's pretty
conclusive i think it's totally
conclusive that it's the safest
but it was portrayed as uniquely
dangerous in part with this idea that
somehow a nuclear power plant resembles
a nuclear bomb even though it's
literally impossible
for a nuclear power plant to explode
given the way that uranium and chain
reactions work
uh so
but unfortunately by tr by making
something a public menace and by
treating it that way what it justified
was an unlimited amount of uh control
and delay for every aspect of the
process and one fact that illustrates
this is since the nuclear regulatory
commission which i think should
basically be called the nuclear
criminalization commission since that
was established in 1975
not one nuclear plant has gone from
conception to completion and the ones
that have come closest have just had
catastrophic cost overruns on the order
of 10 times more expensive than nuclear
plants used to be so nuclear plants you
know you could build them in four years
total now it's 16 or they could be
destroyed
why it should have been that we got them
down to two years like in general we
have evolution
in terms of economic evolution so
nuclear was proven very safe so it's a
total catastrophe that we've stopped
nuclear and criminalized it but it is
never the less part of the world we live
in and thus
we have to you know it could be if if
things have gone differently we could be
half nuclear by now but we're not and so
the idea that we're going to rapidly
replace fossil fuels with nuclear is um
it's unfortunately not even remotely uh
possible although we should certainly
liberate it as soon as possible and i'm
probably the world's biggest advocate
who's actually working on this in
practice with elected officials right
now on how do we decriminalize nuclear
so you mentioned decriminalize i'll use
the word deregulate uh maybe they're
interchangeable uh in many people's eyes
um
there is a very strong argument some
people have making this for decades some
people these are our new arguments uh of
deregulating a lot of these energy
markets so deregulating
a lot of
fossil fuel industry et cetera what are
the implications of doing that both pros
and cons in your mind and is that
something that we should pursue from a
public policy standpoint and uh people
should be calling up their uh elected
officials and really pushing that
forward or is it something that maybe uh
we don't understand as well what are
your thoughts on deregulation
so yeah there's a reason i use
decriminalized versus
deregulate um and if people want more of
a resource i'd highly recommend chapter
10 of the book which is about energy
freedom so the issue with deregulate is
its broad and regulation regulation has
this very woozy meaning and so what it
can it can often conflate two things one
is where the government
one of the two things probably but i'll
give two so one is where the government
is treating us as guilty until proven
innocent and so basically we have an
unlimited obligation to prove that we're
not gonna do something bad and that
leads to potentially unlimited costs
versus the government is protecting
people's rights from violation so an
example would be okay uh in the first
category it'd be okay you have a farm
like you're a hog farmer and every day
there's an inspector who goes to your
farm and checks every little thing to
make sure
that you don't contaminate uh your
neighbor with too much smell versus a
law that says hey there's a threshold at
which you can like emit things that that
go to your neighbors and if you violate
that then you get prosecuted and i'm
very big believer and innocent until
proven guilty and that that should be
the principle for our law and if you do
that you just have to have clear
standards of what constitutes
endangerment so what level of pollution
constitutes endangerment you know um for
that's basically the idea you know what
what um like yeah what point are you is
you know you know what point are you
doing something that is legitimately
considered a threat to others and i talk
about this in some detail in uh in
chapter 10 of the book but so i think of
it as we should have freedom
and then we should protect people's
rights and freedom from endangerment and
we need to define endangerment more
rationally so with nuclear it's not just
about vague deregulation
it's i say decriminalization because
we're treating it as a criminal
enterprise by treating everything as
guilty and and having unlimited danger
until proven innocent
but it's mainly about how do we define
like what is allowed to do in nuclear
and what is not in a way that actually
represents uh how dangerous it is
compared to other technologies i think
if you did that then it would be free
but it's a lot more precise than just
saying hey let's deregulate and then
because maybe you would take away a
crucial protection in that process
is there a country or a region in the
world that you think is doing this well
like like if you had to say hey here's
the example of uh who the united states
should follow or other countries should
follow can you point to one or do you
think actually though this is a global
problem and we've got to uh improve
everywhere
i think the best example would be the
united states 50 years ago
i think that's a much better example i
mean today you would say south korea
is arguably the best
um
you know france but here's the issue
with nuclear so
it's so much
it's been so demonized as dangerous that
it is just it is a government controlled
thing like you think of the nuclear
industry but someone once pointed out to
me there is no nuclear industry at least
in the united states there's a lot of
utilities that own natural gas coal
hydro and then like nuclear is one of
their assets in part because the grid is
so government controlled which is
another kind of an issue maybe for
another day but it's there's not a real
nuclear industry in the us and what we
want is a dynamic nuclear industry where
you you have people starting different
kinds of nuclear reactors in their
garages and i think if you define the
endangerment standards properly you
could totally have that and you would
have a proliferation in the good sense
of nuclear innovation but as long as
it's hey you're only allowed to do this
if the government says this and you can
only do this design
you're not going to make any progress
and i think there's a lot of wishful
thinking by people who are pro-nuclear
that hey this is going to rapidly
replace fossil fuels as long as it's
it's as long as it's this total
non-market it's just going to be a cost
disaster and it'll be stopped and we'll
just keep using fossil fuels plus a
bunch of unreliable solar wind
one of the other quotes that's uh in the
book
that lends support is from peter thiel
obviously one of the world's most
well-respected well-known entrepreneurs
and investors
he says quote the climate debate ignores
the reasons we burn fossil fuels in the
first place alex epstein reminds us that
rich countries may be able to treat
green lifestyles as luxury fashion but
for mo
but for much of the world reliable
energy is a matter of life and death and
quote
talk to me about that this idea of
luxury fashion you mentioned a little
bit earlier about energy poverty but is
it just that people in the western world
were super privileged to be able to even
talk about getting rid of fossil fuels
and like we've literally lost our minds
uh if people that were saying that went
and spent time around the world they
would come running back and immediately
abandon the esg narrative
there's definitely something to maybe i
forget exactly what he said in the first
part of that quote but i think it's it's
really crucial about though ignoring the
reasons why we burn fossil fuels in the
first place and so this is my version of
we're not seriously considering the
benefits of fossil fuels we're just
focused on the side effects now i'm
arguing also where we're what i call
catastrophizing the side effects or
making them far worse than they are
that's why people think that's one
reason why people think oh it's a
climate catastrophe when in fact yes
we've had some warming impact but
overall we're far safer far better in
terms of climate let alone everything
else i think part of what he's pointing
out is yeah you're ignoring the benefits
and then he says well the benefits of
fossil fuels are most obvious for the
people who want to use them but aren't
using them so you think of the people
again who are using less electricity in
their lives than one of our
refrigerators to them it's obvious and
i'm actually really happy that i'm
getting more and more people from the
impoverished what i call unempowered
worlds speaking up about this because i
i since my first book the moral case for
fossil fuels i've been very encouraging
of that and it's really cool to see that
now this other thing about like luxury
things i would agree i would agree that
partial use of solar and wind is a
luxury in the sense of it makes our
electricity more expensive and if you
try to cut costs at all less reliable so
that's what we've had in california i
would argue that's also what's going on
in texas clearly clearly it's what's
going on in california so
but so in that sense yes but i wouldn't
jump to and i don't think peter uh
would either i know has talked about
this quite a bit this idea of a hundred
percent replacement that is not a luxury
lifestyle for anybody because it cannot
be done in a remotely cost effective way
and then what that basically means is
you cannot use much energy and you
revert to a manual labor life so it's
not true there's this narrative of oh
well the poor places needed fossil fuels
but we can afford all solar wind nobody
can afford all solar wind this doesn't
work anywhere even in the richest places
the closest you get are places like
denmark to some extent germany but what
you notice that's in the realm of like
35 germany about 50 denmark just for
electricity mind you but what they're
doing is they have to import huge
amounts of electricity from their more
reliable neighbors and they also have to
have the ability to export it when they
have too much and what we're noticing in
the united states i don't know if you've
heard about these claims about these
predictions of blackouts and all this
risks around the country what's happened
is there are more and more states that
are trying to use more and more
unreliable electricity and saying we'll
import it from others but what's
happening is not everyone can do that
right not everyone can say we're going
to import it from our more reliable
neighbors california tried to get away
with that two years ago there was not
enough as much wind as we expected
during heatwave and so we got screwed
but now it's happening to everyone
because everyone is saying hey let's cut
back on fossil fuels uh and use
unreliable soul and win but don't worry
when they're not working we'll import it
from somewhere else but that doesn't
work if everyone is trying this scheme
and so there's just no
real reality at all in the world of
relying on unreliable solar but again
this is a crackpot fantasy slash
distortion that is perpetrated by people
who don't really care about energy
my last question for you um is obviously
peter thiel probably is the best example
uh very well known for having a
contrarian uh thought process um and
thinking from first principles uh maybe
an elon musk also uh known for being a
first principles thinker
those individuals you would expect to be
able to critically think about uh
a problem like this and come to their
own conclusions and have independent
thought
how do we take the ideas that are in
your book and other folks who have
thought critically about this from a
first principle standpoint and
mainstream those ideas like it's one
thing to arrive at these conclusions
how do you think is best suited to take
those ideas and then get them into the
mainstream narrative to uh at least at a
minimum give people two different ways
to think about it which is one the esg
narrative one kind of this fossil future
narrative
but even to potentially be able to
change their mind and have them see what
some of the errors are in that esg
narrative how do you think about the
distribution of the idea or the adoption
of the ideas
for me the most important thing is to
when i'm making a case like this explain
from the outset like what's my method of
approaching the issue and so i haven't
stressed it that much today but
um it's a really crucial thing that i
think everyone can agree to but few
people practice is that we need to what
i call look at the full context and in
particular we need to look carefully and
weigh carefully the benefits and side
effects of fossil fuels and what i
submit we tend to do is we only look at
the negative side effects but not the
benefits in chapter one i point out that
one of the world's leading thinkers on
this stuff michael mann has a whole book
and he only talks about the agricultural
negative side effects of fossil fuels
but not the agricultural benefits even
though fossil fueled machinery and
fossil fuel derived fertilizer
specifically natural gas are totally
crucial to eight billion people being
able to eat and the lack of fossil fuels
in the world because of ideas like
michael mann's is leading to a food
crisis right now so i think everyone can
agree that we need to carefully weigh
benefits and side effects and it becomes
pretty clear that most of our leading
thinkers aren't doing this but i think
that if we're talking about spreading
the idea it's really about spreading hey
how what's a method we can all agree on
and then let's look at the facts and i
think elon is an interesting example
because i think he's a very good thinker
with certain engineering kinds of things
but i don't think he thinks about this
uh very carefully although i should say
he has well he and i have a bit of a
history he blocked me on twitter for
saying that for writing a popular
article about how the tesla was a really
good fossil fuel car which i guess he
didn't like that although is factually
uh factually true but he has been moving
a bit in my direction i'm not saying
because of b but he's become much more
pro-oil production which he has been
very hostile to for years he's become
more pro-nuclear which he was sort of
subtly hostile to for years and he's
become this is the most important he's
become anti-climate catastrophe so he
had a recent ted if you look at his
powerwall presentation several years ago
it's like climate apocalypse the world
is terrible because of fossil fuels it's
like shows the earth is like an inferno
and now he's telling ted hey look
there's not a catastrophe it's gonna be
great we can just sort of slowly
transition so i don't i can't speak
about where he will be but i i think
it's very important if you want to call
it first principles to have these first
principles for how do you think about
the issue and i found that's made me
effective because i'll just say hey look
can we all agree to think about the
issue that way and everyone says yes
but they wouldn't do it on their own so
it's like it's common sense but not
common practice and by making the common
sense explicit you can make it more
common practice
it's a fascinating way to kind of think
about uh distributing ideas and getting
them uh actually adopted and and shared
um
i lied i have actually two more
questions the first okay can i can i say
something about peter thiel though
absolutely um
in particular and this is this is my my
uh
my necessary like hard sell type thing
for fossil future but it's it's it's
somewhat time sensitive so uh peter
got to know pretty well over the years
and i'm grateful he's endorsed both my
books and one thing we did recently
was we did a 90-minute conversation at a
guy named a guy also really my name
palmer lucky's house he created oculus
and sold it to facebook and he now runs
an amazing defense company called
ondrill anyway he hosted this event and
we recorded it and part of i asked these
guys to do it because i wanted something
to incentivize people to order fossil
future on launch week so if you order a
fossil future on launch week and you
just send an email to fossil future alex
epstein dot com so fossil fuel alex
upstand.com then you'll get this whole
90-minute discussion with me and peter
my follow-up discussion with palmer and
a whole bunch of other cool resources
and if you want to know more you can go
to fossilfuture.com but i know people
here are really interested in peter in
particular so i'm very deliberately
offering this to you as a carrot so that
you buy the book this week and then it
gets more well known this week uh
because the more well known it gets the
more
these ideas have a chance of of
penetrating the mainstream even more
than they already have okay that's
that's fantastic way to uh to drive some
book sales
it's nice that they agreed to that you
know that was uh getting getting uh two
guys like that to agree to help my
pre-order campaign was uh and we had an
amazing live event but there were only
like 70 people there so it's it's
amazing that they allowed that and and
we can uh hopefully get a lot more book
sales out of it i love it um
the uh the next question that i have i
guess is uh
what can people at home do
like obviously they can read the book
they can get the ideas how can they help
push these ideas forward
love questions like that uh so
the you know one thing i created i have
a sub stack page alex epstein
epstein.stack.com and probably by the
time people are hearing this the second
or third article will be called
something like
easy and effective ways to uh promote
fossil fuel to promote these ideas so
one thing i talk about in chapter 11 is
that people have not yet caught up to
the reality that sharing effective
resources is incredibly effective and
it's it's kind of a weird thing because
it sounds so cliche to say share things
and of course people will always say buy
my book and stuff but it's not really
about books and in some way books are
inferior for sharing because you have to
buy them
but there are a lot of really good
resources on any given topic that if you
share them with people like that's going
to be much more effective so i don't
know what those are in bitcoin but i'm
sure that they uh i mean i know of some
of them but i don't know the most sort
of absolutely effective ones but for
example on energy one thing i've created
is called
energytalkingpoints.com my energy
talkingpoints.com is totally free thing
initially i created it for clients and
elected officials i work with but it's
available to everyone and if you go on
that site you can search any topic and
it's very likely you're going to get a
twitter length talking point with a
really good reference and the idea was
to just make a comprehensive thing where
you could just have the right answer on
any kind of issue uh and it's persuasive
it's concise and it's it's accurate so
that's one thing
and then the other thing um so i think
already i've created all of these free
shareable resources and you can you can
really change uh the world by
influencing the right people like even
something like asking um you know asking
the right host to have me on or someone
else you have on like you know people
do you know dave rubin is i do i'm
guessing you've been on the podcast
before yeah
yeah yeah so dave so he's an interesting
example where he had listeners harassing
him for a year to have me on and then uh
and so he finally had me on i guess he
gave in and it was i think it was really
popular and like i get recognized on the
street for that and i was talking like i
won't name names because i don't want to
out anyone but like one of the really
really successful person in hollywood is
a huge fan of my work and like he
learned about me from the dave rubin
show and is kind of spreading the truth
about fossil fuels
in hollywood like that's just think
about that that was just some annoying
fan was bothering dave rubin and it led
to like a big hollywood person learning
about it so you
you cannot underestimate the power of
you sharing i would just say the thing
that you want to focus on is how good is
the resource because if you share
something that is really going to be
persuasive and powerful to someone who
disagrees with it or will empower
someone who agrees with it to become
more effective either of those two then
it's going to be effective if you just
send them something that's just some
partisan nonsense that only appeals to
you and to no one else then they're just
going to consider you their annoying
friend or relative so
like my whole focus is creating these
resources that are designed to persuade
people who expect to disagree and that
empower people who already agree so
fossil future that's the best one if you
can pay 27 bucks on amazon but
energytalkingpoints.com is awesome and
it is totally free
my last question one of our sponsors is
uh eight sleep they're a
thermoregulated uh mattress and uh they
make it super cool or you can make it
super hot and uh they help you get
better deeper sleep what's your sleep
schedule and you know you're running
around you've got a bunch of stuff going
on you got the book release etc what
does that sleep schedule look like right
now
i think i generally do well in most
aspects of human flourishing you
probably see the sign besides my book
like i'm very into human flourishing um
i'd say sleep is a little bit of a
weakness
of mine relatively speaking but i have a
strength that someone somewhat offsets
it in my view actually significantly
which is that i'm an amazing napper and
in particular i live i live like 150
feet away from my favorite beach in
laguna beach and i take naps two or
three times a day
and
i feel amazing like i have really really
good energy uh and i have that like
amazing and the the weird thing about it
is i take 22 minute naps and what i do
is i listen to old episodes of sight and
they're all old i listen to seinfeld
episodes and i've memorized them all to
such a degree that it's like meditation
and i just fall asleep and i wake up at
the credits it's it's bizarre uh but
it's unbelievably effective so that is
my sleep
method
i love that
that's amazing where can we send people
to uh to find you on the internet
oh so i am really big on twitter so
twitter alex epstein actually just
finally have my personal website up
alexepstein.com and then that website i
mentioned before
energytalkingpoints.com and yeah if you
want to get in touch with me um you can
message me on twitter i have open dms um
not always the best of them and my email
address is alex at alexis.com i read
everything don't necessarily respond but
i like to be accessible in case anyone
wants to send me something amazing that
i'll learn from
this is uh uh this is amazing man i
appreciate you uh one doing the work two
writing the book um and uh and then
taking the time to uh to come on here
and talk i learned a bunch oh yeah well
you were one of the ones i wanted to go
on you were like on my top 10 list
uh from the beginning so it's it's very
and then we took [ __ ] forever to get
you a book uh because we put the wrong
address on but uh i'm glad we got it i'm
glad we got it to you and sorry i only
gave you like a day to read some of it
before i was reading my ass off man i'll
try to read as much as i could um the
book's name is fossil future why global
human flourishing requires more oil coal
and natural gas not less alex epstein
thank you so much for doing this and uh
we will definitely have to bring you
back as uh as all this continues to
progress
thanks man and hopefully sometime in
person i'm in in miami quite a bit